prove that this number three vm + 70 n
is always divisible by 10 provided and
this is the part well this is the main
part that's different
provide that that n is not just a
positive integer but that it's an odd
positive integer so that requires some
extra thinking which I'm going to get to
in about 45 seconds ok so firstly what
is always the initial step when you're
doing mathematical induction we we test
right now
you're always thinking right what's the
first actual value so often it's N
equals 1 but sometimes as you might
notice it might be N equals zero or
might be some other arbitrary value in
this case look at the question read it
what is the first possible value that n
can take in this case it's 1 but not
just because we default to 1 1 is the
first odd number right there's another
one it might even be the previous one
where you've got even ends so ends not
gonna be 1 for that case right it's
gonna be most people say too but zeros n
even numbers are anyway we'll get into
an argument that later on I'm going to
test that N equals 1 now mercifully this
is quite easy to do so 3 to the 1 plus 7
to the 1 is 10 and I'm going to write
that as 10 times 1 there you go it's the
product of two positive integers one of
them 10 I'm good to go okay now here's
where it starts to get different because
of this oddness okay if I assume that N
equals K right sorry
assume true for N equals K okay
[Applause]
this gets a bit tricky okay because n
just can't be any number right and has
to be an odd number okay now I can just
say that this is true for K is an odd
positive integer okay but the problem
with that is that I can't use any of the
properties that odd numbers have right
odd numbers are special they're not just
anything I can actually say some special
things about them right so instead of
saying N equals K what I'm going to do
is I'm going to say how could I write
this to guarantee that this number will
be odd now there's lots of ways to do
this okay let me show you one example
and then tell you why we shouldn't do it
to K minus one okay now if K is a
positive integer if K is a positive
integer this will be odd do you agree
with that like say for example a
positive integer like 7 2 times 7 minus
1 will be 14 minus 1 and 13 sure enough
is odd so I've successfully you can keep
on doing this right I've successfully
guaranteed that this is going to be odd
but watch what happens with this number
where's the place this number gets
substituted in to have a look look up
it's on the board where does it get
substituted into it's gonna get
substituted into two indices do you
notice that it doesn't just go anywhere
it goes up in the exponent
now that causes me a bit of a problem
because watch what happens don't write
this down if I put in that right I'm
gonna get 3 to the 2 K minus 1 plus 7 to
the 2 K minus 1 okay now if I've done
this all correctly there's no problems
with that it should still be divisible
by 10 for the particular values I want
but think about what this means right
what is 3 to the power of negative 1
it's a third and what about 7 to the
power of negative 1 it's it's 1/7 right
now this is all still true except it's
gross right because I'm trying to deal
with this
ability which is all about whole numbers
right and I've just introduced a whole
bunch of fractions in there I'm just
kind of making life hard for myself it's
all still true it's just a really
inefficient path to go around so instead
of doing this I'm going to do this okay
it's still going to be just as odd as
before but it's not arbitrary right it's
not just like oh this will be more
convenient for me it's more convenient
for what reason look at what happens
when you substitute this in you're not
going to introduce fractions into this
does that make sense you see there's a
reason why it's this it's not just some
rule like don't use negatives because
because someone told you to write
there's an actual instrumental reason
why you're trying to make this easier
for yourself and avoid this some
alphabet soup is bad enough but it's
really bad when there's fractions in
there are you trying to deal with whole
numbers does that make sense okay let's
write the assumption out it's going to
be 3 to the 2k plus 1 plus 7 to the 2k
plus 1 what am I saying about this
what's my assumption that it is it's
divisible by 10 so I'm going to write it
as this where K and P are positive
integers are you ok with that
so note by the way K can be any positive
integer it K doesn't have to be odd does
that make sense because look if I put in
any positive integer into this I will
still get that being odd and that's the
real condition I need to meet are you
okay with where I'm going so far ok now
a few of you have asked me hey can I can
i muck about with this can I write it
differently for example can I write it
like this and take that plus 1 out of
the index like so can I do that and the
answer that question is when you get
simultaneous equations and you have to
solve like say 5x minus y equals 7 and I
don't know 4x plus 2y equals 5 right
there's lots of ways to solve this what
would be a common way to do it what
might be an easy way that would get rid
of some numbers or some printables
really easily if this was say equation
one and equation two for me
I'm either going to solve this by
substitution or elimination if you have
a look at this guy here right do you see
there's something really easy I could do
to this that would make it eliminate
nicely what would you do this line or
you could make why the subject and then
do it by substitution
I'd have to subtract 7 from both sides
but just as easily I could take this
whole equation and I could multiply it
by 2 and then both ways I got to get me
in on top okay now what you're doing is
you're producing an equivalent version
of this which is easier to work with
right this is an equivalent version of
your assumption that is arguably easier
to work with because you don't have to
worry about so many indices does that
make sense so I'm actually going to use
this as my assumption okay